Is there a concrete example of something
where you,
you said you said something,
and I'm not thinking of anything in
particular.
I'm being entirely genuine year.
Is there an instance where you,
where you feel you said something that
appeared to be true to you at the time
and knowing what you know?
Yes.
I think I was little.
I think I was a little dismissive of the
men going their own way because I think
I called them pathetic weasels,
which,
and I had my reasons for that.
My reasons were roughly speaking,
who are the men going their own way
frequently?
Well,
there are a group of people mostly on
the net who have had,
who've been burned in their
relationships or who conceptualize
themselves as having been burned in
their relationships and they believe
that the legal structure in particular
in western countries is so tilted
against men,
particularly in family dispute
situations that end divorce settlement,
that it's safer for men not to establish
permanent relationships with women,
not to cohabit with them ever and there
are large movement now.
How large they are.
I don't know,
but they're large enough and they have.
What I would regard as an undue
influence over relatively bitter and
resentful young men who haven't had
great success in the dating market and
who are looking for a rationale to write
off all women because they are so hurt
by their continual rejection and that is
not good for those young men,
and so the reason that I disparaged the
men going their own way was because I
had seen the pernicious effect.
These are often older guys,
the pernicious effect of their world.
Weary philosophy on young men.
Now these guys think that they're just
warning them and they are warning them,
but they're not just warning them.
Now,
the reason I really regret calling them
pathetic weasels is because they also
have a point.
I do believe that the court systems are
staggeringly anti male,
absurdly horribly anti male,
and I've seen my own clients,
some of them who are really,
really decent,
hardworking,
family oriented people demolished by the
court systems and and so the men going
their own way have a point.
And so I'm sorry that I called them
pathetic weasels,
but I.
But I outlined my reasons and so yes,
I do regret that I have to be careful
because I do have a satirical,
dark,
satirical sense of humor and I can outer
epithets,
let's say for the sake of punctuating
appoint well simultaneously forgetting
that 150,000
people will listen to it.
So.
So I regret that.